find out what I could about gpt5 I have
read every academic paper I could find
about it every leak report interview
snippet and media article I can
summarize it like this it will come down
to data how much of it there is how it's
used and where it comes from these are
the factors that will dictate whether
GPT 5 gets released later this year and
whether it will actually approach genius
level IQ some media reports have picked
up on this potential leak about gpt5 you
can read it here I have put quite a few
hours in trying to verify whether this
might be accurate and even though it's
now being quoted by reputable sources I
still can't confirm its accuracy so for
now I'll just say that the rest of the
document seems accurate but who knows I
am not relying on this for my research
about gpt5 but the scale 25 000 gpus
does seem right tech radar here
describes Chachi BT as having been
trained on 10 1000 Nvidia gpus and don't
forget those were a 100 gpus Microsoft
might well now have access to the h100
GPU which according to every source is a
big step up from a100 gpus on pretty
much every metric and what about
timelines for GPT 5 would later this
year be accurate well we can infer from
Geordie rybass that gpt4 or equivalent
was completed sometime around late
spring early summer of 2022 that would
be just around the time that deepmind
published this which in massively
oversimplified terms lays out a
framework for optimizing parameter size
with the number of training tokens AKA
how much info from the web it's trained
on turns out models like gpt3 and palm
had way more parameters than needed
anyway it was the data and especially
high quality data that it was lacking so
all those laughs about gpt4 needing a
hundred trillion parameters were
absolutely farcical it could even be
that gpt5 has the same or fewer
parameters than gpt4 this less wrong
post from July of 2022 picks up on that
finding and points out that it is Data
not size that is currently the active
constraint on language modeling
performance current returns to
additional data are immense and current
returns to additional model size are
minuscule indeed most recent Landmark
models are wastefully big if we can
leverage enough data there is no reason
to run 500 billion parameter models much
less 1 trillion parameter or larger
models remember it's data not parameter
count the link to all of these articles
by the way will be in the description at
this point let me quickly say that if
you're learning anything don't forget to
leave a like or a comment frankly even
abuse helps the algorithm so go for it
what about chat GPT while gpt3 along
with a host of other models was trained
on about 300 billion tokens by the way
what defines a token shifts in the
literature but it's somewhere between 1
and 1.4 words therefore think of a token
as roughly one word as you can see from
the graph below Palm was trained on
about 800 billion tokens approximately
deepmind's chinchilla on about 1.4
trillion tokens that particular less
wrong post was referenced here in this
academic paper released in October this
paper is absolutely key to this video
it's focused entirely on whether we will
run out of data as it pertains to
machine learning and large language
models one of the key takeaways of this
paper is the approximation given the how
much high quality data slash tokens
might be out there the stock of high
quality language data is approximated at
between 4.6 trillion and 17 trillion
words the next point it makes is key we
are within one order of magnitude of
exhausting high quality data and this
will likely happen between 2023 and
2027. for those that don't know being an
order of magnitude bigger means being 10
times bigger than what came previously
now I want you to remember that 2023 to
27 timeline for a moment because first I
want to mention why high quality data is
important running out of that could mean
running out of the rapid improvements in
GPT models the paper says models trained
on the latter kind of high quality data
perform better so it is common practice
to use high quality data for training
language models and where does that high
quality data come from well to be honest
not knowing that is a big part of the
problem which we will definitely come
back to but here is a rough idea we have
scientific papers books scraped content
from the the web the news code Etc plus
Wikipedia of course the paper also
mentions here the middle of the road
estimate of nine trillion tokens of high
quality data available that estimate
will be Central in defining the
near-term future of artificial
intelligence one order of magnitude more
as an increase in performance is a huge
deal that would change everything but I
must say this estimate contrasts with
some others such as the 3.2 trillion
token estimate from that original post
and the author did say that they were
trying to make it an overestimate and
what about this from David Chapman a PhD
in AI from MIT he references the
deepmind study and that less wrong post
and makes two important and plausible
observations first that gpt4 or Bing may
have scraped the bottom of the web text
barrel and that this might be why it's
responses sometimes turn out like
emoting teenagers I actually did a video
on the crazy conversations you can have
with Bing that you can check out after
this one but second He suggests that
there might be a reason that neither
Google nor open AI have been forthcoming
about where they get their data from now
I'm not saying it might be about
illegality but it might be about
avoiding controversy over attribution
and compensation take me I have math
tutorials on the web that I'm sure have
been scraped and now lo and behold Bing
can teach math I'm not complaining but
it would be nice to at least know what
has been used and what hasn't this of
course mirrors the Raging legal issues
around AI image generation fights that
are only just beginning for these web
tags wanting to know where the data came
from is going to become a huge issue and
this article lays out just some of the
surprising sources of data for Google's
bad model check out one of them which is
YouTube could it be that your comments
right now are being harvested quite
possibly I want to get back to the
central question what are the gpt5 well
here on the far right is Google Palms
performance which if you remember back
from the earlier paper was powered by
only 800 billion tokens and palm was
definitely not optimized for parameters
GPT 5 will learn the lessons from this
and will probably scrape as much high
quality data as it possibly can and
don't forget another year has gone by
since gpt4 was handed to Microsoft and
the stock of high quality data Grows by
around 10 annually anyway even without
further efficiencies in data use or
extraction so even if Bing did use all
the high quality data available I don't
think it did and even if David Chapman
is right the stock of data now available
is going to be greater but if Bing was
trained on a similar amount of data to
Palm say one trillion tokens but now GPT
5 maxes out we could genuinely be
talking about an order of magnitude
Improvement I'm going to briefly survey
some of the implications of that in a
moment before I do I want to show you
the ways the openai will likely be
improving GPT 5 regardless of previous
limitations first more ways might be
found to extract high quality data from
low quality sources no offense Facebook
second this paper from only last week
shows that gains can be made by
automating Chain of Thought prompting
into the model if you're not sure what
Chain of Thought prompting is it's a
form of prompt engineering that I
discussed in my video eight upgrades in
gpt4 where essentially you force the
model to lay out it's working and
thereby improve its output now this
paper talks about two to three percent
gains but even though small gains when
Bing is already this strong would be
significant don't forget these are
separate upgrades to the data discussion
third this paper from three weeks ago
shows that language models can teach
themselves to use tools such as
calculators calendars and apis if there
were no other improvements honestly in
GPT 5 other than this it would change
the world and I know for a fact that
people are working on integrating
Wolfram Alpha into a large language
model and look at the number of tools
that Wolfram Alpha has in science math
money and more these models can actually
teach themselves how to use tools and
that Chimes perfectly with this paper
which essentially lays out that using a
python interpreter models can actually
check if their code compiles and thereby
teach themselves better coding the links
to all of these papers will be in the
description as I said the fourth way
that GPT 5 might be improved even
without more high quality data would be
it being trained multiple times on the
same data as laid out here by Professor
swayam dipta he says that currently
these models are trained on the same
data just once owing to Performance and
cost constraints but it may be possible
to train a model several times using the
same data sure it might cost more but I
think that for Microsoft when all of
search and its profits is the prize a
few billion could be deemed worth it and
this paper co-authored by that same
Professor lays out how models can
generate additional data sets on
problems with which they struggle such
as those with complex pans and that
humans could filter their answers for
correctness think of this as artificial
data generation and it can lead to 10 or
more in improvements and if artificial
data can be integrated honestly what is
actually going to bottleneck these GPT
models I could go on with the
improvements that might be made without
new data my central point is that data
will be the big determinant but there
are other ways to improve gpd5 if data
turns out to be a bottleneck what if
they can fully utilize 9 trillion tokens
as the original paper surmised by the
end of 2024 or even the beginning of
2024 what could one more order of
magnitude Improvement actually look like
the short answer is that no one knows
probably not AGI but certainly a
revolution in the jobs Market maybe this
is why Sam Altman tweeted 2023 thirty
thousand dollars to get a simple iPhone
app created 300 for a plumbing job I
wonder what those relative prices will
look like in 2028 the likely coming
Divergence between changes to cognitive
work and changes to physical work could
be quite dramatic that gives a sense of
his timelines but my own guess is that
the best human raters will be beaten on
at least some of the following
benchmarks take reading comprehension
where you can imagine the extrapolation
to gpt5 if and when it occurs that would
have huge implications for summarization
and creative writing next logic and
critical reasoning we're talking
debating topics doing law work
Discerning causality in complex
scenarios that would be huge in finance
where you have to sort the signal from
the noise in large data sets physics and
high school math would be close to
solved by an order of magnitude
Improvement AI tutors replacing my job
for example could be with us by the end
of next year don't forget the release of
GPT 5 in whichever month it comes will
likely roughly coincide with the final
refinements in text to speech image to
text text to image and text to video
avatars so don't think AI tutors are as
far as you might imagine the reason why
no one on and certainly not me can be
sure of timelines for GT5 though it's
because they depend partly on internal
Safety Research at Google and openai
take this quote from Sam Altman to the
New York Times and when we are ready
when we think we have completed our
alignment work and all of our safety
thinking and worked with external
Auditors other AGI Labs then will
release those things here he's probably
talking about gpt4 but the same would
apply even more so to gbt5 on the other
hand the release and then on release of
the Sydney model of Bing might suggest
otherwise but at least according to him
safety and Alignment are the goal I'm
going to end with this quote from
samuelman again he added the blue text
last minute to his public post on AGI
released the other week it says it's
important that the ratio of safety
progress to capability progress
increases in other in other words these
models are getting much more powerful
much faster than they can keep up with
but thank you for keeping up with this
video thank you for watching to the end
please do check out my other videos on
Bing chat and its use cases and either
way have a wonderful day